all right Barbara
Barbara where are you from originally
where'd you grow up um Massachusetts
tell me about your childhood growing up
um my childhood I like playing sports my
family had a tar Court in the back but
it was supposed to be at a tennis court
for my mom but it never got finished but
we had a basketball hoop and I played
basketball every day
I loved it I ended up going to college
and get a scholarship for basketball
scholarship at Manatee Community College
that's great
how was your childhood in general how
would you describe it
um
just like everybody else I guess it was
just I enjoyed playing outside we had a
big backyard a family we're close to
family every other weekend would go
either to my mom's parents house or or
my dad's parents house and we had a lot
of friends that live in the
neighborhoods and play with them and
always look forward to go and visit the
family and because most of the people in
the family didn't Branch off like now
all the grandchildren and the nieces and
nephews live all over the country but
before everybody was centrally located
my mom's family was in New Hampshire and
Vermont area my dad's family was in
Rhode Island
hmm
tell me about your adult life so you
went to college yes and what'd you do
after that
um
I went and started being a nanny for for
um different people and I always enjoyed
the kids and um
so did you get married yes I got married
about uh it was my husband and I were my
men at church and we were married for 17
years and and
you guys lived in in we lived in
Sarasota I met him at church in Sarasota
and then something happened
at some point right yes
well tell me about that um
December 18 2011 my husband now we're
finishing up a paper out six o'clock in
the morning and we were hit by a drunk
driver going 110 miles an hour head on
they instantly killed my husband the
other driver died and I was bay-flighted
to Blake Medical Trauma Center they said
at that time and the 23rd of November in
2011 Blake Trauma Center opened their
doors as a trauma a trauma facility I
wouldn't have made it to Bay flight to
Tampa or St Pete and um
so
because of my extensive injuries I was
Bay flight into the hospital where I had
critically a lot of injuries
so your your husband passed away on this
at the scene yes
how has that affected your life it must
be it was it was it was it was hard not
only did I wake up with my only my eyes
and knees working with the tube down my
throat to help me breathe in an induced
coma for a month and a half for for a
month and for two weeks I was in the
middle induced coma I woke up after
taking my tube out of my throat I
started asking questions like where's
Curtis what happened to me what was
going on the family told me that he's in
heaven he he didn't make it through the
accident we were hit by a drone driver
and
um I I it was devastating not only
physically but mentally emotionally and
spiritually I was broken I have a faith
in God my faith is a strong faith in God
but I didn't know where he was why would
I go such through such a trial I
couldn't understand why I was the only
one that survived and I mean when I met
my husband we are inseparable we did
everything together we you know we I
encouraged him he was working at a
company we first met we were he was
working at a company where he did window
and screen repair and I said why don't
we do our own business and so he said
well how are we going to get customers I
said well you know I'll just knock on
doors and we started our business for
ourselves and we did well we had several
businesses together
window washing service auto detailing
and then we you know he had the paper
out
um but I miss him terribly you know it
was it was devastating for me and then
when I had to face the issues of my body
being broken I had my compound fracture
in my left ankle where I almost had to
amputate it and they saved my foot I
have rods and pins I have multiple
fractures in my legs rods and pins
holding me together there I broke my hip
my pelvis C2 fraction in the neck I had
to wear a halo for three and a half
months and one of the things that I
thought about was
you know
why like the the doctor said I would
walk again and I believe them but they
said to be a year and a half and because
of the weight-bearing status I had on my
legs I had to do physical therapy and if
I didn't have physical therapy after two
weeks after six weeks in ICU at Blake
Thomas Center then they said this is all
we can do she's had all the surgeries
she's ready to go and because I had
insurance I was able to go to a rehab
and start doing exercises to get me
prepared so when April 3rd would come
then it'll be able to put weight on my
legs then I was able to
um you know have that have that happen
um
and I started and it was a i my world of
recovery started with one blink for yes
and two blinks for no because when I was
in ic when I was in the first two couple
weeks in the hospital because of the
tube down my throat I wasn't able to
communicate but the doctors did both one
blank for yes two blinks for no
wow
and so not just you're not only
recovering from the Indus injuries
you're also recovering from losing your
husband yes terribly
how many how old were you when this
happened
it was 12 years ago I'm 50
55 so 42 43 43
my husband was 50. yeah
how do you
move on after that
um
it's tough some days are better than
others for the most part I have a lot of
friends that support me and
um
you know one of the things that
I think about is
um
you know we all have trials in our life
and I feel like I overcame and got
through this through the help of people
praying for me my faith in God and um
but that still doesn't take away the
fact that I have loneliness sometimes
without him I feel like
um sometimes I wish I could get up and
ride my bike or you know go for a run or
anything and sometimes it's struggle
just to get up and walk you know uh at
first there was
um I was in the wheelchair for for
several months and then uh and then a
walker then it would then a cane and
then you know I had a brace on my left
leg and they said I would have to work
the rest of my life but as you see I
don't have it so I was overcome that
obstacle as well
your children no we don't have any
children
you have friends though yeah a lot of
good friends it helps a lot of good
friends they were able to send me
um post
emails at the hospital and that was
encouraging because they the Nur the the
candy striper would come up to my room
and say oh you had an email come in
today and I said can you read it because
of course I can't read it I can hold any
things my hands are broken too and um
so she'd read it to me and it was such
encouragement I'd get encouraging words
of how good I'm doing the proud of me
they're praying for me Bible verses and
able to
really feel like they care and they you
know they care about me and they
um they even film me
um and and played it live at church and
and I was able to talk to them
is it did you find it difficult to
continue believing in God after
something like this just randomly
happens
um yes and I'll tell you after like
three weeks after the accident I watched
this pastor on TV talk about God's
goodness and Grace and count your
blessings live one at a time don't Focus
too much on the past don't dwell upon
the future live one at a time and count
your blessings and I started thinking I
was kind of I had anger in my heart
because I was like count my blessings I
have nothing to be grateful for all this
has happened to me and then my I talked
to my sister she came in that evening
and I said you know I told her what
happened with the the seeing that Pastor
and what he was talking about and she
said Barbara well you have something to
be grateful for I'm here I'm with you
right now and look at the sunlight it's
coming in and warming to bed and I
thought to myself you know you're right
I have 10 fingers and ten toes I'm going
to challenge myself to count to a
hundred things to be grateful for before
I go to bed and I did I challenged
myself it started to change my heart not
only did I have Despair and darkness
overwhelming but I started to have a
grateful heart and I felt like
I can do this with with with the help of
others whether it's the therapists the
doctors the nurses I can help with my
friends in the prayers that they've been
giving me
I can't get through this and I will and
I will walk again they said I will walk
again even though I said a year and a
half but I was walking in three and a
half months and I still had to be in the
wheelchair but I was still walking
therapy and around the unit and
everything
yeah and and you're now
deceased husband would want you to
feel that way you know it's funny
because one of my girlfriends when when
I was first skating I was moved down to
the fourth floor for like the last week
of my stay at Lake and um and these my
friend my sisters oh don't don't talk
about Curtis don't talk and don't get
her upset when they came in to see me I
said guess what and they go what I said
I bet you Jesus got the best base for
Curtis up in heaven and not only is he
playing the bass for the praise team up
there but he's taking care of the
animals because he liked iguanas snakes
Turtles uh gerbils cats and you know any
type of animal he loved them and I'm
believing that he's taking care of the
animals in heaven
press it sometime
over this yes yes I do you're lonely
I have a lot of good friends that I can
call and right now my mom is um
needing more help around the house uh
but she's she's
she's just uh you know we have to
someone has to be with her all the time
you know we have to do that and it gives
me a sense of purpose
you know and I have a volunteer for a
lot of Ministries in Sarasota Angels
Attic my girlfriend's Ministry uh latest
Grace bags and I help and this helps
feed include the homeless leads Grace
back Ministry and I um
I do that and of course you know just
learning I like to learn new things I
like to go on YouTube and learn new
things I learned how to make journals on
YouTube and what I did is I designed
150 journals Dolphins cross Birds fish
Hearts doves Angels 150 journals from my
pastor so when she on her on her
Facebook page on her um Amazon page she
wrote a book and then now she has 150
journals on there and I helped make that
happen and I I really like you know the
challenge of learning something new
and uh so there's always interesting to
find something on YouTube to learn it's
just that that gives me passion gives me
uh helps me get focused and and learn
you know learn more it's great that
you're able to rebuild your life so
nicely yeah yeah what is your view of
alcohol being
readily available to every you know
anyone over 18 or 21.
um yeah
anywhere in the country because it's
still A Dangerous Drug yes it is and now
that you know this
um
how do I feel about that
I I kind of feel that if it's done I
mean
you know something
I never really thought of that what
you're asking me how do I feel about the
drinking I had to forgive the people in
um
you know that were that were there at
the uh evidently the driver who hit us
he was at a party and he was leaving six
o'clock in the morning he headed home
and I feel bad for the people at that
party letting him drive
because not only did they lose a good
friend but he caused this accident
hitting us head on a hundred miles an
hour
he he was under the influence of drugs
and alcohol you know
it's sad a lot of this goes on in the
world everywhere it's not just America
it's all over the world
and
you know all I can say is
I forgave him
and because the resentment and the anger
of my heart for losing my husband was
strong and and it was hard but I started
just counting my blessings and whenever
I had those negative thoughts I would
dismiss it and say I'm not that was in
the past now I have a future and I don't
want my future to be something I'm
dwelling about what happened in the past
I wanted my future to be something where
I could just grasp and realize that yes
God loves me even Jesus had to go
through a hard time for us
just think of that in itself
all the things that he had to endure
and so I wouldn't wish this on anybody
if I can discourage that one person and
say hey you know what he can't go where
he needs to go right now he has to take
those keys and hide them
we don't want to kill our friend because
we're going to feel bad in the end
it's those people and I know somebody
had a conviction in their heart saying I
shouldn't have let him drive I was I was
the one that was supposed to be the
designated driver and I didn't let him
drive I know conversations like this
happen at parties not in some parties
it's just been
everybody's out of it but I feel my
heart that somebody was there saying I
should have took his keys
look what happened to that poor lady
lost her husband she's in the hospital
you know
you know it just is
it's getting you know it happens it
happens a lot it shows you the power
power of forgiveness though yeah you're
able to move on from it yes because
there's no way you'd be able to do that
if you weren't able to let go in for you
right
and Barbara what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
all of this
well
I meditate on his promises in the midst
of my difficulties
and I take away from all this that I can
overcome anything any trial I have in my
life
I think to myself it's not as bad as
what I went through I might be going
through a tough time whether it's you
know worrying about my mom or worrying
about my I've had friends have heart
attacks of the friends that were in car
accidents other friends and just
realizing that
being able to
be grateful have a grateful heart it's
it's just life-changing literally come
when you count your blessings and try to
come up with a hundred things to be
grateful for
it changes your whole mindset because
you're out of a desperate and despair
and hard hardened and and anger
Viewpoint turns into something positive
so isn't something where you have
ability to
um
be grateful
because if you have that grateful and
more I'd lived one minute at a time at
times one minute when they had to do my
therapy and my hands were all they broke
off my hands and this finger is healed
didn't heal as well as the doctor wanted
it to and um but I can do that I can do
that I tried so hard to make that go
straight I tried so hard for a long time
but it does its own thing and the doctor
said we can fix it and I thought what
are you gonna do and we have to break it
I said no thank you I need my cane this
is my hand came the the hand that goes
on the cane I need this right now and I
said whenever you're ready and I said I
don't think so I'm that's a reminder to
me what I overcome and what I'm able to
to accomplish in My Life and Overcoming
all this adversity in this hardship and
sadness
I just feel so blessed I looked down and
it could it really was pulled from one
side to the other and and that's the way
my foot was I had one when the doctor
was releasing me after all my Dr Alan
validay he had all the doctors in the
area my my hand doctors and my legs and
everything he had I only had to go to
his office for my x-rays and he would
send them out to the other doctors
instead of going to tampons and pee all
these other places
and I asked him I said did I almost lose
his foot because the scar is from one
side all the way to the other side and
they said you did and I'll tell you the
story we almost lost your life a couple
times Barbara you're a Survivor and he
said to me when you came in and at the
accident we had two doctors on each hand
a doctor on each leg and a doctor a
doctor on the spleen what Dr Kimball
said Mr Dr balady I need your help over
here this is not going well we're going
to lose her he says if I don't do this
on her foot she's gonna lose her foot so
Alan validay went off of my right leg
and put a Halo on my second leg tried to
make it so it could happen come back and
then Dr Allen Arthur valade came with
Miss Dr Kimball and dropped my spleen
under control and it was so serious he
said he said he never had that type of
surgery that he had to do to be a part
of but that was a new beginning for him
because now he knows that he can do it
too
and so I I just think to myself how
fortunate I am to
be able to walk
be able to have grateful heart be able
to
share my story somebody out there is
going through a tough time right now and
I know it I feel it it happens to
everybody and if they can get out of
this story how they can overcome
through
through your prayer prayers of others
through praying for for your own self
and well-being but just realize that
everybody has a lot of different
situations that happen in your life good
some bad but we can move on
we can move on get through things with
God's help he can do it
all right Barbara thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you so much for
having me I'm glad you're doing well now
yes thank you very much you're welcome